hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so i've been working as a
professional trailer for the past
six years in hong kong and i've just
started to make some youtube videos
because i want to show you guys all the
different tools and techniques that i
use at work
every day to make money on the markets
so basically my job is about
reading the flows so i use technical
analysis
as a kind of survival kit to show me
the levels and stuff like this but i
mostly you know i use the
finance mechanisms and try to understand
what is creating any move and who is
creating which moves so i can guess what
is the next
move so today i want to show you an
example of how i do this with rkt
let's get into it
[Music]
so this is our rkt rocket companies so
i'm talking about the stock for like a
couple of weeks
because i have a signal all right so i
sum things up my signal is given by a
trend line
so very basic stuff you can see guys i
connect this high and this high
here i have my breakout and when my
breakout is actually retested
this i don't need it anymore we tested
here and then we go higher
and then same thing we tested here we go
higher and here we're just you know
going
unfortunately this trend line is going
lower guys all right so
it will still hold even the price action
is going lower so if you are along the
staff it's of course
not an easy position to to bear
it's actually carrying negative if we
can say
things like this so yeah i think the
price action is actually holding above
this trend line
and this is the reason why i expect a
big move to happen
it's not happening we had it here with
very huge volume and then it got
hammered here so i need to understand
what is happening who is doing what
so to do that i go on market watch you
know just stop rkt
i'm just going to show you guys you know
once again the purpose of my videos is
that
everything i do you can do it i don't
use
any expensive data you know this is
public data all right so
outstanding number of shares public
float percentage of short interest
short interest millions of shares right
you have everything here
and i just use all this data that i put
here on this table so it's published
every fortnight
and i try to analyze the situation so i
use the equity float and the outstanding
number of shares to know if the company
is emitting shares if yes
like for example fubu tv is doing or amc
is doing
this is creating some delusion all right
so they're basically using
shareholders money to raise cash through
equity
and they can for example pay back the
debt like gamestop wants to do as well
or just you know finance some projects
whatever
but it's putting not just selling
pressure it's just putting
some downside pressure on the on the
price uh on the stock price
but it's not bad it's better than to do
this than just raising money through
that with very expensive rates
so here it's not coming from the equity
flows
what are the hedge funds doing the short
interest was at 40 million of shares
so around 40 so quite heavily shorted in
feb
and since the 26th of feb it's actually
decreasing by 10 million
every fortnight since the 26th of feb so
let's see what it did
what happened to 26th of february so
this is a short squeeze guys and
now we know it then they did it again
two weeks later so here again and they
still have 10 million shares
to buy i mean i'm not sure they're gonna
buy back everything
but maybe they know something we don't
all right usually hedge funds
are sellers i mean when they are sellers
because they are they have good reasons
to sell
and here they are buyers so i'm not sure
actually who is putting this selling
pressure
on the on the stock price it's not the
firm it's not hedge funds
so it's just there is a turnover of
some people who don't believe in it
anymore who wants to lock profits
and some some new investors so it's
going to take some time but there is no
more sending
pressure on the company and we have 10
million more shares
to be bought so i guess you know they do
it every two weeks
so they did it here second of march
here 29th of march so it should have
been today maybe they're a bit late
maybe they're gonna do it you know in
two weeks again
i i'm not sure i'm not sure exactly who
is doing what but i can see these flows
that repeatedly are coming in the market
at least they came twice so i expect
them maybe to come one more time
so my conclusion here technically we are
bullish hedge funds
are not putting any pressure on this
price actually they are putting now a
buying pressure
the company is not emitting share so
they are not
in need of money which is good so i see
only good things you know
then some fundamental analysis would be
actually very welcome here
uh it's not my specialty you know it's
not what i what i do the best
if you guys like the stock do your own
dd
and find some information that are going
to tell you if yes or no
it's a stock you should buy or not but
for me technically we are bullish so
that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the
sub like and bell button so you're gonna
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys